-Our first guest tonight
is a Peabody-winning comedian
and actor you know
from "Patriot Act,"
"The Daily Show"
and "The Morning Show."
His comedy special,
"The King's Jester,"
is streaming now on Netflix.
Let's take a look.
-In the Middle East,
Indians, Pakistanis, Bengalis,
Sri Lankans, we're the help.
Right? We're the Mexicans
of the Middle East.
[ Laughter ]
Even Brown people
have their own Brown people.
That's how those buildings
got there!
The only people that love to
[bleep] on Indians
more than the Saudis
are the Brits.
[ Laughter ]
The only difference is,
we love when the Brits
[bleep] on us.
[ Laughter ]
There are Indian uncles
here tonight that are like,
"Wow! London decor!"
[ Laughter ]
-Please welcome back to the show
Hasan Minhaj, everybody!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Welcome back to the show.
-Thank you!
-Congratulations
on the new special.
It must be so great
to have it out.
-Yeah, it's a huge relief
to just get it out.
I --
We've seen each other recently.
-We have.
We were at a --
We did a charity event
for the Natural Resources
Defense Council -- NRDC.
-Yes, NRDC.
Not the Department of Defense.
It sounds like that.
-It does sound like that.
-Yeah, it's these weird --
People don't know this --
we're in the Illuminati,
and we do these --
we do these gigs for,
like, billionaires,
and we all know
billionaires love, um...
saving the environment
and tax loopholes.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
When you can have the same --
When they have both
in the same night...
-Yeah, just, mm!
And then you get the call from
Seth, and it's a stacked lineup.
-It was a great lineup
that night.
-And everybody bombs.
-Yeah.
-Like,
you do your best material,
and the room is always like,
it's the founder of Uber,
Condoleezza Rice and the ghost
of Winston Churchill.
[ Laughter ]
And everybody
is just shooting air balls.
Like, you know how hard it is
when you're just
giving your A material,
and they're just like, "Mm."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
And then, when you angrily yell,
"You're not better than me!"
and they're like, "Actually..."
[ Laughter ]
-"I own the six media companies
that run the world."
You're like,
"Please, pick up my pilot."
Yeah, it's good.
-You --
We were talking backstage
at that event.
You have two kids now.
-Yes.
-How have you found fatherhood
in the early years?
-It's so crazy, because,
for years, my wife and I,
we were trying to have kids,
and then we finally had kids.
And now, we have a daughter
that's 4 and a son that's 2.
And we just got
pushed out of the city.
We were
in a two-bedroom apartment.
I was in Hell's Kitchen
for years.
And then, when my son was born,
I was just asleep
in the living room
with my mother-in-law,
and I'm like,
"I didn't think my comedy career
was supposed to start --
end where it started."
You know what I mean?
[ Laughter ]
Like, I've worked
too hard for this.
So we moved to Connecticut,
and...
I can feel you judging me.
[ Laughter ]
I know everybody's judging me.
We live in Greenwich,
Connecticut, which is like,
"Get Out" white.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Like, everybody there
either works at a hedge fund
or is a war criminal.
[ Laughter ]
Like, sometimes a little bit
of both, right?
And -- And every morning,
I just see all the --
you know, the bankers and
traders in Patagonia puffers.
And my daughter will be like,
"Who are they?"
I'm like,
"Look, babe, it's criminals."
[ Laughter ]
"They're the reason
daddy doesn't have a pension.
You know, it's them."
[ Laughter ]
But it's so weird.
You get to do parent-teacher
conference now, right?
-Yep, it's very nice to be
in person and do them again.
-Is it nerve-racking for you?
-It is very nerve-racking to me.
They often tell me hard truths
about my kids
that I already knew.
[ Laughter ]
-For me, it's -- has it hit you
that you're a parent?
Because for me, we had our first
parent-teacher conference,
in person, and I remember
they were saying all this stuff
about my daughter,
and I was like,
"What are mom and dad
gonna think?"
And they were like,
"You're mom and dad."
And they gave us this envelope,
and I was like,
"Beena, we gotta hide this.
Like, we can't --
Yeah, we don't want mom and --"
Yeah.
That's still in me, where I'm
37, but it's still like I'm 27.
Sometimes, me and Beena will be
holding hands in public,
and if we see
Indian aunties or uncles,
we'll just drop hands
and Euro step around them,
and then hold hands again.
I'm like, "They can't tell
people in the community
that we're dating."
[ Laughter ]
"What am I doing?"
-One of the things I enjoy
about being a dad
is reading books to my kids.
-Yes.
-Are you enjoying that part?
-Okay, so one of the things
I love doing now
is reading with the kids,
because we're making
new memories.
I remember growing up,
I wanted my dad to read to me.
I was like,
"Will you read to me?"
And he's like, "I send you to
school, so you read to me."
-Oh, interesting.
-Yeah!
So, like, now I'll be like,
"All right, let's --
let's read together."
Now, are you an old-book
or new-book guy?
-We are old-book people,
which I'm trying to change.
I appreciate there's a lot of
great authors right now.
-Yourself included.
-Thank you very much.
Thank you for the mention.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes. But the old books
are terrifying.
And the new books
are just kind of weird.
All right, so the old books,
we're doing all the classics.
You know, we're doing
"Cat in the Hat,"
and then you're like,
"Oh, my God.
This drug-induced cat
on ketamine..."
-Yep.
-"...bursts in to their house,
two children, alone,
destroys it,
with Thing One and Thing Two."
That probably offends somebody.
-Yep.
-Really, they're just things?
-[ Laughs ]
Within one page, they sober up,
clean up the whole place,
they leave.
[ Laughter ]
"Where the Wild Things Are"!
-Yeah.
-All right,
these negligent parents
send their kid upstairs
with nothing to eat.
He has to go across the ocean,
befriend monsters,
and then finally
comes back to his family.
Horrible.
Then there's "The Giving Tree."
-Yeah, that's a rough one.
-Just really --
That's just like
"humanity is awful."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-"Don't trust anybody.
They will destroy everything."
And so I was like, "All right,
let's try the new books."
-Yeah, you brought one.
-So we got gifted this.
-Okay, this was a gift.
-All right,
this was a gift we got.
-Okay.
"Little Feminist."
-"Little Feminist."
[ Laughter ]
Great message.
I think we're all on board.
-Yeah.
-Most of the country.
[ Laughter ]
And I'm reading it
to my daughter, and she goes,
"Oh, my God!
Like, Daddy, who's that?"
I go,
"That's Queen Elizabeth I."
She goes, "That's amazing."
And I go --
she goes, "Who's that?"
I go, "That's Sacagawea."
And she goes,
"Daddy, are they friends?"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Are they..."
"Well...no...
No."
She goes, "Why?"
And I go,
"Well, one could argue...
she's dead because of her."
[ Laughter ]
Then she was like,
"All right, who's that?"
She saw this little Brown girl
in the corner.
I go, "That's Malala!"
And she goes,
"Are they friends?"
[ Laughter ]
And I was like,
"Absolutely not."
[ Laughter ]
And she goes, "Well, why?"
And I go, "Well, because Malala
is from Pakistan."
And she goes,
"Well, why is that a problem?"
And I go,
"Well, one could argue..."
[ Laughter ]
"...Pakistan's a country
because of her."
[ Laughter ]
And she was like, "Cool!"
I'm like, "Not cool."
[ Laughter ]
"You know what?
Let's just, um --
Let's just read
'The Giving Tree.'"
[ Laughter ]
-"The Giving Tree"
is maybe less triggering.
I've got a lot more to ask you.
We'll be right back with more
from Hasan Minhaj, everybody.